Welcome back. Now that we have a fairly detailed understanding of what patterns of insights are,
what bus metrics are and how we can use them to tailor our analysis for a particular data set,
we are going to try and apply it on this particular data set that is the Titanic data set.
Essentially this is a data set which contains details of about 800 passengers that were
unfortunately aboard the Titanic in 1912 when it sank. And the idea is how well can you predict
who's going to survive and who won't survive. So we already have this data set downloaded,
you can just search for this data set on Kaggle, you can just Google Titanic data set
and the first link probably the first link you're going to find is the link to the Kaggle data set.
You'll just have to go ahead and download the data which we have done and we have it here.
So this basically is the main file in that data set. Let's go ahead and open it.
So there we are. Let's maximize this a little bit. Let's zoom in
and also let's freeze the top row as is the custom and there we are. Now we are ready for
some analysis. Now one of the first things we are going to do is instead of diving headfirst
into the analysis we are going to draw on the patterns of insights that we have learned
in an earlier video and try and see if we can come up with certain questions based on those patterns
and then we are going to use those questions to drive our analysis. Essentially we are going to
go through each pattern of analysis and see what sort of questions we can draw from it and instead
of doing the analysis willy-dilly or just going through multivariate, bivariate or
multivariate analysis we are going to use these questions and try to find their answers through
whatever analytical tool that we can come up with. So let's try and come up with a list of questions.
So let's try to write down our questions here. Let's just simply rename this particular sheet to
patterns of insights and there we are. Well this too needs to be zoomed to 200% let's say
and the first thing we are going to need is a list of columns because until we know what each
column means we wouldn't really be able to come up with questions. So let us copy over the columns
from the first row of the sheet. Now I can straight away see that passenger ID is just
an idea of the passenger so we're probably not going to need this column because we can
do nothing with the ID itself. So let's copy the remaining columns and paste them over here.
Actually we shouldn't be having them like this. Let's try and lay them out in rows so we can do
something like transpose of this particular selection and then close it and there we are.
So we can try and see if we can delete this. Well you see we can't delete this because then
the transpose will mess up. So let's leave it like that. Let's just delete this particular row.
There we are. So we have the name of the column and let's also add what that column
means. So if we look at the column survived we see that it's basically a column which has values
in 0 and 1 and if you go back to the page from where you downloaded this data you'll see that
these are basically binary indicators of whether a particular passenger survived or not. So
essentially a 1 means that a particular passenger survived. This particular person
Mrs. Jack Heath Futrell she survived but Mr. William Henry Allen did not survive.
So let's try and add that information here.
These comments are later going to help us when we try to frame up our questions.
E class is essentially again an integer indicator of the class of the passenger. So essentially
third class, first class and second class. So here we can simply say
passenger class, name is self-explanatory, sex is self-explanatory, age is self-explanatory as well.
We don't know what sibsp is so let's go back to the date to the page where we got the data from
and look at the data dictionary and here what they have said is that sibsp is the number of
siblings or spouses about the Titanic. So essentially for each passenger how many siblings
or spouses overall were about the Titanic. So let's just call it let's just simplify it say
number of siblings and spouses. Well you would assume everybody to have only one spouse but
you never know. Then again the next one is part which is the number of parents or children about
the Titanic. So we have siblings classified separately and parents and children classified
separately. Ticket, so ticket I think is just the ticket number and that I guess is just going to
be another unique idea. So not going to help us really. Then passenger fare is self-explanatory.
Cabin is something interesting, it's like cabin number. It's possible that multiple passengers
shared a cabin so multiple people could have a cabin number and let's say and we have also
something called embarked. So let's see what that means. Here the data says that embarked is basically
the port of embarkation. If you go back to the original data set which is in this particular sheet
we see that embark contains S, C and Q, three different unique values that keep on repeating
and the website tells us that C is Cherbourg, Q is Queenstown and S is Southampton. So let's just copy
this and paste that into our data dictionary. So now the next thing we are going to do is try and
look at some patterns of insights and based on that try and see if we can come up with some
questions. So let's try and do that. So the very first pattern of insight that we know is as we know
called an unknown result. So these are the most common types of patterns that are the most common
types of insights that we're going to draw. Let's simply list down a bunch of things that we might
want to generally find out through this data set. So these would all be unknown results so far because
we know nothing about the data so far. Obviously since it's a data set about the passengers of the
Titanic we might want to find out what is the survival rate. Now we know that this is going to
be a low figure. Essentially the Titanic disaster is known as one of the worst maritime disasters
in history and that is for good reason that is simply because a lot of people died but
exactly how many people died is not something we know and what is the probability of somebody
surviving on the Titanic is also not somebody we know. But since it is widely considered a disaster
we can safely assume that the probability is less than 50 percent of the survival rate is less than
50 percent. Whether it is actually less than 50 percent or not is something that we'll have to
verify through the data set. Well the other thing that we could find out by simply looking at these
columns is that what is the survival rate by class. So by passenger class what is the survival
rate. If you've seen the movie you might have seen those scenes where people from the second
and third classes were locked up or people from the first class or the higher classes were given
preference when the ship was being evacuated and when the lifeboats were being filled. We
have now an opportunity to figure out whether that was really true or whether it was just a
figment of James Cameron's imagination. Let's see if survival rate differs by class and if actually
the lower classes had a lower survival rate. Well one obvious thing that we know about the Titanic
is that women and children were allowed to evacuate the Titanic first. So essentially
survival rate by gender should be higher for women than for men. Let's see if that is true
and if actually it is true which probably most likely it is. Let's see what is the difference.
The other thing that we have is couple of variables related to families.
So we could also ask something like are people traveling with their families
more likely to survive. So this is something that we can infer from these two columns over here.
So that's it like those are broadly a few general questions that we can ask. Oh and we also have
the fare as a variable which is how much the ticket had cost. So we can also ask something like
apart from this is basically an extension of the survival rate by class problem. So we can ask
something like given that we have fare were people who paid a higher fare more likely to
survive. So let's find that out as well. So yeah those are broadly the kind of questions that we
can come up with when we think of unknown results as a pattern of insights. The next pattern of
insight that we know of is called surprising comparison. So these are essentially questions
like how does the survival rate compare between say gender, passenger class. Now maybe couple of
these questions we have already addressed here but anyway let's put them down here in the interest
of completeness. How does the survival rate compare between age for example are younger people more
likely to survive or are older people more likely to survive. And yeah the other one other variable
which we have not used so far is the embarkment. So whether you embarked on Cherbourg or Queenstown
or Southampton which of them makes you the most likely or the least likely to survive. So
how does the survival rate compare between embarkment ports. Let's just call this
embarkment for the sake of convenience. There we are and then we can also ask some other
question based on you know this particular pattern of insight based on say the family
so we can say that how do number of family members compare across gender. So basically
do men have more family members or do women have more family members. Passenger class
and what this means is that which class of passengers has more and less family members
traveling with this. Then age which what age how does the number of family members vary as
your age changes. So you would imagine that younger people children would be traveling with their
family members and older people might not be traveling with their family members. Let's see
if that is true and again as usual the other variable that we have is embarkment. So let's
see what happens. Now the next pattern of insight that we have is surprising
extremes. Let's see what sort of thing we can come up with over here.
So here we have to frame questions that are in the superlator. We ask questions about highest
and lowest and things like that. So let's think about this. Yeah one question we can ask is
which passenger class had the highest or the lowest women passengers or you know
passengers
which passenger class had the highest or the lowest men or women. So gender ratio across classes.
Let's see what that gives us. We can then ask who are the oldest and the youngest people in each
class. So we are basically trying to combine extremes between the class variable as well as
the age variable. We can also say what was the highest or the lowest fare and then we can group
this again by age by gender by passenger class and by embarkment. So there is a bunch of things
that we have which we can use to do our analysis and of course like we can also say what is the
highest or lowest fare by survival because ultimately one of the things that people believe
about the Titanic may be perpetrated by the movie is that people who paid higher fares were more
likely to survive. Let's see if that is actually true. Then we also have abnormal distribution as
another class or another pattern of insights. So let's see what sort of distribution we expect
from this and what do we actually get. So we can ask something like what is the distribution of
passengers across well age passenger class fare. I'm not even sure if that really makes sense or
not like basically how do you even compare how many passengers paid what kind of fare.
Not sure if that really makes sense but let's leave it here for the sake of completion. This
is basically more of an exercise in how we frame questions rather than how we actually do the
analysis. The analysis is something that follows and anyway once we take a particular question and
try to tackle it how we exactly do the analysis and does the question itself make analytical sense
becomes a different argument completely. What is the distribution of passengers across
embarkment. So essentially you would expect that few children very few old people but a lot of
young and middle-aged people would be there by age. By passenger class you would expect that
very few people are in the first or second classes and a lot of people are there in the third class
as is true for most modes of travel fare. Again not too sure let's find out and
embarkment again we don't know what are the distributions of passengers that embarked in
CQRS so let's take a look. So I guess this is a fairly large set of questions that we have
and let's tackle them one by one through our analysis and see what we can get to.
So let's go back to the sheet with the data and try to start answering our questions.
Well the first question that we asked was what is the survival rate and that can be answered by
looking at this column. We essentially have a binary indicator which tells us whether a
particular passenger survived or not. So let's try and take a look at how we would solve this.
Now one way to calculate this is simply count the number of ones that are there in this whole
column and divide them by the total number of rows. So essentially we can simply say
sum of a to a and then simply divide it by the count of a to a. Now we see that we get the value
of 0.38 which means that the survival is 38 percent quite less than 50 percent as we expected.
So essentially what this means is that 38 percent of the passengers on the Titanic survived.
Now if we look at the formula here very carefully you will see that count a to a is the same as the
length of that column and when you have the sum of a column divided by the length of a column
that's nothing but the average. In general whenever you have a binary variable like this one or a
Boolean variable like this one the average is often a proxy for the probability of the positive
class. So instead of using this particular somewhat convoluted formula we can simply replace it with
average. So we can simply say average of a by a and that gives us the same value and that's a
good proxy to have because average is a formula that we are familiar with and it avoids us writing
a complicated formula. Now the next question that we had was what is the survival rate by class.
Now we have the survival rate in this particular column and we have already calculated it overall
and we have the class over here. So what we need to do first in order to find the survival rate
for each independent class is to filter this particular column by a particular class value.
So basically for the third class take all the rows which have three in this particular column
and then compute the survival rate for those rows separately then do the same for the first
class and then do the same for the second class. Now this is called a group by operation and one
easy way to do that in excel is to use a pivot table. So let's write this down
and let's go to the next cell and in order to create a pivot table we go to the insert tab and
we click on pivot table. Now it's going to ask us to select a table or range and it has very
helpfully already selected a range essentially all of these this boundary that you see with
the dotted lines that's basically the range that it has already selected for us and what it's going
to do is that it's going to use all of these columns to create the pivot table of course which
individual column to use for a particular metric that is up to us. So let's click on okay and here
we see the details of the pivot table. Now we need to find out the survival rate by class so
we need a table which shows each class in a given row and in the row next to it we need to see or
in the column next to it we need to see the survival rates. So what we need to do is take
the p class variable from here and drag it down to the rows section and then we need to take the
survive variable and drag it down to the values section. Now you see that it has already picked
a particular aggregation for us which is sum of survived. We don't need the sum here we actually
need the probability which in this case is also the average. So in order to change the sum to
the average we can simply right click on this particular field and go to field settings and
here as we see we have multiple different aggregations which are available to us and
the default value is sum we simply change it to average and then we click on okay. So there it is
those are the survival rates or probabilities of particular classes. Now in order to make it a
little more readable let's sort this in a descending manner by the average of survived. So essentially
we know that 62 percent passengers from the first class survived, 47 percent passengers from the
second class survived and 24 percent passengers from the third class survived. So this is fairly
significant and it's also fairly depressing in a way because what this means is that of the people
who were there in the first class for every three people roughly two of them survived whereas in
the second class every one out of two people survived whereas in the third class one out of
four people survived. So there is clearly a significant distinction between the survival
rates of the different classes that were about the Titanic. Let's take a look at the next question.
The next question is what is the survival rate by gender? Now the answer to this is not something
that should surprise everyone we clearly know for a fact that women would have a higher survival
rate but that is also something that we know from our general knowledge or whatever but let's see
if the data actually holds up and again to do that we have to create a new pivot table. We are
going to use a ton of pivot tables in this particular exercise by the way simply because
pivot tables are so convenient and they allow us to do a bunch of different operations very quickly.
So again we go to the insert tab and we click on pivot table it's the same range as usual and the
when we want to place the pivot table is this particular cell m10 and that is what it has
basically already selected over here and then we click on okay. Here we basically need in our rows
the sex because we want to figure out what is the survival rate for each individual gender and then
again we drag the survived column into the value section and here also as usual it's basically
giving us the sum. We don't want the sum we want the average so again we go to the field settings
and then we change the sum to average and we click on okay and there it is. So 74 percent of
the females about the Titanic survived whereas only 18 percent of the men about the Titanic
survived and that is obvious because we know that it's basically the females and the children who
were allowed to evacuate the sinking ship before anybody else. So that answers our next question
which is what is the survival rate by gender. So let's add this also here.
Let's give this a little more room so that we can read what we have done.
Let's go to the next question now and see are people traveling with their families more likely
to survive. Now this is a somewhat compounded question it's a somewhat complicated question
we don't know how to straight away answer with this because in our data set we don't see a
straight up column which tells us whether a particular passenger had a family on the Titanic
or not. However we do have two other columns from which this information can be derived. We know
for each passenger how many siblings were on the Titanic or spouse and we also know for each
passenger how many parents or children were on the Titanic. So what we can simply do is take the
sum of these two columns and that output the sum of siblings or spouses or parents and children
and children essentially gives us the number of family members that were there with a particular
passenger on the Titanic and if this number happens to be greater than zero then we can conclude that
somebody has a family on the Titanic. So let's try that. In order to compute this variable we'll
have to introduce a blank row and then fill that row with the sum of these two columns and then
see if that column is greater than zero or not. So let's insert a particular column that gives us
this column. Let's simply call it n underscore family which is the number of family members you
have and then we can simply do sum of this column plus this column and press enter. So there it is
this particular person which is Mr Owen Harris-Brown had one family member on the Titanic
and as usual we can simply drag this down all the way in the end
to apply that particular formula to the entire set of rows and we overshot it a little bit but
that's okay we get a bunch of zeros we can just reduce it a little bit and go down to
exactly 892 columns and there it is. So now we have a column which tells us what is the total
number of family members a person had when they were on the Titanic. Now we can simply convert
this into a Boolean variable. Basically if you remember the wording of our question was very
specific what we are asking is are people traveling with their families more likely to
survive which means that all we need to answer is whether somebody was traveling with their
family or not because whether they survived or not is already available to us here. So essentially
we just need to perform some sort of a logical operation on this column which tells us that
if this number is greater than zero then that person was traveling with their family or if
that number is zero then that person was not traveling with their family. So let's introduce
another column which we will simply call as family and in order to populate this again we
simply do an if operation. So an if is basically a formula which takes in a particular condition
and if that condition is true it picks one value and if it is not true it simply picks another
value. So let's say that our condition basically is h2 greater than zero and if that is the case
we want to call it true and if that is not the case we want to call it false and then we press
enter. So let's copy this and paste it all the way to the end of the sheet it went well beyond
the range so let's not do that because that will slow down the operation and let's go back to the
top and let's just drag this down until we reach 892 columns. There is a keyboard shortcut for this
basically you can just press a particular keyboard shortcut which will take you down to the end of
that particular data not to the end of the spreadsheet completely but somehow on my
computer i can't seem to make it work. So there it is essentially this particular person had five
family members therefore they were traveling with a family this person had three family members
so they were traveling with the families and others were not. So wherever there is a zero
we conclude that that person does not have a family and if there is a one then that person
has a family. So let's go back all the way up.
Now the question we had was is a person with a family more likely to survive or not. So
essentially what we need to do is find the survival rate depending on whether a particular
person has a family or not. So again we use a pivot table go back to the insert tab click on
pivot table and the same range is selected the new output range of the cell is also selected
you click on okay that gives us the pivot table and then we say that what i want in my rows is
basically whether a person had a family or not well it seems like those particular columns are
not showing up. So let's see what went wrong with our selection let's close this and delete this
particular pivot table well we can just instead of pressing the delete key we can just press
the undo key to make this work. Now let's see why it did not create the pivot table correctly for
us remember that we need the i column over here when you click on the pivot table you see that
it's only picking up to the it's actually picking up the has family column itself so
let's see why it wouldn't pick up the pivot table also.
Well let's see if we can directly select the columns like that and then make a pivot table.
So essentially instead of making a selection on its own we are creating a pivot table
by ourselves so we make the selection and we click on the pivot table and we say that we want
to place the pivot table in the existing sheet over here basically. So essentially let's click
on okay now we have the ith column and this time it says that a pivot table cannot overlap another
pivot table well we did not remove the original one so let's do that and then again select all
the rows from all the columns from a to i and click on insert pivot table again we want the
result to come up in the existing sheet which is over here let's click on okay
and there it is we have the has family variable available to us so let's drag that down to the
rows and let's as usual pick the survived column and drag it down to the values the sum which is
the default aggregation let's change that to average so instead of getting the total number
of people who survived we'll get essentially the probability of them surviving and there it is.
Essentially the idea is that if you have a family you have a 50% chance of survival
if you don't have a family then you have a 30.3% chance of survival.
Let's see how we can make this a little pretty we want to make it descending and we don't want
to see any blank values so there it is and let's again format this as percentages just in the
interest of better presentation so that it is nearly 51% people who have a family survived and
only 30% of the people who did not have a family survived now one of the reasons why
this could happen is that you can imagine a typical family consisting of a father a mother
and two or more children or even one child and you see that since women and children were evacuated
first it's possible that even within a family the rate of survival is something around at least
50% because there would be a man and a woman and if there are children then the rate of survival
would be more for if you consider a given family as the unit which we are considering for this
particular probabilistic analysis so that's why it makes sense that people who were traveling
with families had a higher rate of survival the only way that you would not survive if you
were in a family on the Titanic is if you were a man so that's why this is not too surprising
let's see what our next question is so were people who paid a higher fare more likely to survive
now let's think about how we could calculate this what we can do is simply have the fare over here
and let's format this as currency so here we can go to the formatting tab and we say that we want to
format this particular thing as a currency now clearly it has picked the Indian rupee
as the currency symbol but we can go a little ahead and click on more number formats and instead
of the rupee symbol we can use the Great Britain pound the reason I've chosen Great Britain pound
is because the Titanic started its voyage in England and it was going to the US so the fares
are likely to be in British pounds not in American dollars or rupees obviously so let's leave it at
that and there it is the idea is that we now want to figure out does paying a higher fare mean
that you are more likely to survive let's think a bit about how we would do that here again also
it's a case of bivariate analysis where we have one categorical variable which is simply true or
false and we have one numerical variable which is the fare so does increasing fare mean a better
chance of survival let's think about it well since one of our variables is actually a categorical
variable here also we have no choice but to do a group buy essentially we are going to figure out
if somebody survived or not and then check the average fare they they pay so essentially we can
say something like average fare by survival and again let's insert another pivot table
so here's basically seem to have messed up the selection but let's cancel it anyway
and let's restart again I clicked in the wrong place and that messed up the selection
so here's a selection and we want to place the result in the cell o 18 which is basically the
cell and we click on okay and here what we want to do is we want to have the survived factor
as our rows and we have the fare factor in our columns and here we have some affairs again let's
change that to average pairs one of the reasons we use average so often is because it gives us
the best of the worst kind of an estimate so there it is the people who did not survive
had an average pair of 22.1 gbp whereas those who survived had an average pair of 48.39 gbp
clearly means that the people who survived were basically paying more than twice the amount
on average of people who did not survive this is also a very stark contrast and
somewhat surprising result because you would not expect to find any correlation between
what fair people are paying versus whether they survived or not but anyway that's what the data
tells us so let's continue so the next question is amongst surprising comparisons how does the
survival rate compare between gender i think this is something we have already answered so if we go
back to see the survival rate by gender we have already answered how survival rate changes from
men to women so that question is answered we have done the same for passenger class but we have not
done that for age essentially we need to see how survival rate changes as your age group changes
now in order to do that we are going to have a slightly complicated type of a pivot table
so let's take a look
so let's write down the metric we are trying to measure here which is
rate of survival by age now here too we need a pivot table so let's go ahead and
insert a pivot table same range and there we are now here amongst the rows we basically want
ages so let's take the age column and drag it down to rows so there we have all the different
ages that are present in the data set we see that it's a fairly large list we might want to
group it down but see let's see what happens and again as usual in the values let's drag
the survived column here again it's the sum of survived instead of that let's do the average
of survived so there it is now you see that we have ages which are 0.42 0.67 1 2 3 4 9 basically
all integer ages are there there are also floating point ages in between so instead of dealing with
ages as the raw numerical number that they are let's group them together into pins and one way
to do that is to simply click on one particular age value in the table and click on the group
selection button over here which is available under the pivot table analyze tab of excel and
so when we click on group selection it gives us a menu so it's basically saying that starting at
0.42 which is the lowest value and ending at 80 which is the highest value we want to group the
whole range in groups of 10 let's start a little lower than 0.42 because we want the range to
slightly exceed the actual range and instead of ending at 80 let's end at 90 and group it into 10
and then when we click okay we see that the data becomes a lot more compact and instead of having
a survival rate at each unique value of age that is present in the data set we get aggregated
survival rate for different ranges of these values now those are our values let's sort this
by decreasing order and we want to sort by the average of survival so there it is basically
anybody who is between 80 to 90 years of age had a hundred percent chance of survival but at the
same time that you see that somebody is between 70 to 80 percent of age has a zero percent chance
of survival this probably is a fluke value what that means is that there's probably one or two
passengers who are in that age range and it just so happened that both of them survived or whatever
number there were in that range happened to survive and that's why it's getting a high rating but
you know the same cannot be said over the values clearly for lower values which is 0 to 10 or
we see that the survival rate is pretty high which is 60 percent that makes sense
children were allowed to evacuate first but at the same time if you look at the range of 10 to
20 years the survival rate falls a lot more below so there it is these are the different
survival rates as grouped by age
now the next question that we have is
how does the survival rate compare between embarkments so let's try that as well here
again let's click on the cell where we want to add our pivot table let's go to insert and again
insert a pivot table same range and when we click on okay we get the pivot table menu
here we are talking about embarkments so let's drag to back to a rows field and survive to the
columns field and change this to average and there it is so again we can clean this up a little bit
say that we don't want to see the blanks we want to sort by the age of survived in a descending
order and there it is so basically the people who embarked on c which is let's take a brief look at
what that is Cherbourg Queenstown and Southampton so basically the people who embarked on Cherbourg
had the highest chance of survival whereas those who embarked on Southampton had the lowest chance
of survival let's select these and format these as percentages in the sake of better presentation
so there we are so you see that most of these questions we have been able to answer through
a variety of pivot tables and that is why if there is one thing that you learn about excel
it's probably going to be pivot tables so that's pretty useful so let's proceed to our next set of
questions the next question is how do family members compare across gender so essentially
what we need to do is find out how many family members on average each particular gender had
so we can say something like this number of family members by let's say gender and let's insert our
pivot table over here so let's go to the insert tab click on pivot table and this time we want
to group the number of family members by gender so what we need to do is put the sex in the
basically the sex column from here we want to drag it into rows that gives us male and female
and we have we still don't have the number of family members columns which is n family again as
happened in the previous case the selection has failed to take these things into consideration
let us try and recreate the table again so let's undo this and see if we can create
this particular table and we also had basically the gender column so then again we click on
insert and we click on pivot table so there it is it has not picked up the correct one but we
can add it over here we can say that we want to pick up the range from
b and we want to pick up the h so there it is we only want it to pick up these two values
and that's good enough for us and we want to add the result in an existing worksheet which is this
one over all the way over here so let's click on okay it says that the data source reference
is not valid let's see what can go wrong over there let's cancel this and actually force select
all the can columns from a to h and that should give us a correct selection for the pivot table
so there it is and we want to add it to the existing worksheet over here and then we click on okay
and if you look at it yeah this time the number of family members has come up so let's say that
we take the sex in the rows column that gives us male and female and we also take the n family
members in the values column again let's convert the sum to an average
and there it is so here it is and let's clean this up and say that we don't want to see any
blanks and reset the table so phi waves had almost twice the average family members than men and this
is also understandable probably because women were not allowed to travel alone and they would
be accompanied by their family whereas men could travel alone and there it is so basically that's
basically how number of family members varies by gender so the next question is how do the
number of family members compare across passenger class we could simply create another pivot table
but for convenience we can just modify this existing pivot table so let's see how to do that
we can just delete this particular row from here we can say remove field and since we want to have
a comparison across the number of family members which we already have the average of here and
amongst the rows we want the passenger class so we can just drag this over here and that's how
it changes so let's also try and modify this a bit we can say that we want to see this in the
descending order by the average number of family members and not want to see any blanks so there
it is so that makes sense essentially between the first and the second class the average number of
family members is 0.7 and in the third class it's one so essentially most of the people
in the third class on an average were traveling with one other family member
whereas people in the first and the second classes had smaller families
now the next few questions which is how do number of family members compare across age or
embarkment those are simply modifications of the same pivot table that we have already added
so you can do them as exercises but let's move on to the next pattern of insight which is
surprising extremes so let's take a look at the first question that we ask which passenger class
had the highest or the lowest passengers so let's take a look at this this also requires
a kind of a pivot table but a slightly different aggregation so let's go and insert
the pivot table over here say that's the correct pivot table here we basically want to insert
the passenger class along the rows now in the values since we simply want the count of the
passenger class we can take any other column so let's just take something like survived but this
time we instead of the sum we want count so when we go to field settings and we can simply replace
them by count and click okay so that's basically the idea in the first class we had 216 passengers
in the second class we had 184 passengers and in the third class we had more than twice of
any of the other two classes 491 passengers so that makes sense like third class was the largest
class of passengers let's move on to the next question which is
which passenger class had the highest or the lowest men or women so let's take a look we can
again insert a pivot table and here also we need to do a count so along the lows we want
the passenger class and along the values we want the sex fields but here in the case of
this particular sum we basically want to change it so that we can just do a differentiation between
men and women so it seems like this is not something we can have over here we can also drag sex into
the columns so that will basically give us the male and female part separately so there it is
essentially in the first class there were 94 females and 122 males in the second class there
were 76 females and 108 males and in the third class there were 144 women and 347 males we can
also take this a step further and actually calculate the gender ratio so essentially that
is simply the number of women divided by the number of men in that particular class and let's take a
look at what that tells us so we have this value you'll see that a large formula has appeared here
that is because this is not a literal value this is a computed value the pivot table has actually
computed that value for us and then we divide it by this particular value and we press enter
and that's basically the gender ratio for the first class again let's do the same here we say
that we want to divide this value slash this value and there it is and then again for the last class
we say we want to divide this value by this value and then again for the sake of presentation
let's format these as percentages and here is where we see our first surprising output
essentially the gender ratio of the third class is the lowest of the three classes we have
steadily decreasing gender ratios between the first and the second class but they are still
fairly high 77 percent and 70 percent but the gender ratio of only 41 percent is too low
why this is important is because the gender ratio in the third class of passengers was very low
it is also possible that it is because of this that their overall survival rate could have gone
down now we can divide the passengers into using any of these columns essentially we can divide
them by survival you can divide them by passenger class we can divide them by age also sex also but
that is trivial we can divide them by age and you know where they particularly embarked and so on
whichever way we try to divide our passengers if in that particular cohort or in that particular
classification of passengers there are more females then it is likely that the survival rate
of that particular group of passengers is going to be higher so essentially if we were to divide
them by class and we see that a particular class has more females then the overall survival rate
of that class gets pushed up at the same time if we were to divide age groups into a bunch of
if we were to divide passengers by age groups and if a particular age group has more women in it
then simply because there are more women in it and because women were basically allowed
to evacuate the Titanic before them and that fact alone pushes the survival rate of that group
so basically so far we have seen that the survival rate by class of the third class is very low
and one of the reasons why that could be happening simply is because their gender ratio is very low
if they had enough if they had a high enough representation of women well representation is
a wrong word if they had a high enough gender ratio then it's possible that their overall survival
rate could also have increased
so there we are and let us continue with the questions
now you see that many of the following questions can also be solved again just by extending the
same sort of pivot table and cross tabulation that we have been doing so far so let's jump
directly to the next section of insights which is abnormal distributions so let's take a look at
what is the distribution of passengers across age one quick way to do that simply is to draw
a histogram and as we know we can simply select a column and go to the insert tab where we are
going to see a bunch of charts now let's take a look at recommended charts sometimes what you
find is directly available in the recommended charts and there it is so we want to draw a
histogram now what this tells us simply is that most people fell in this particular bucket which
is basically the age group of 17.5 to 23 years so most people were actually between the age of 17
and a half and 23 years we had quite a few people who are below six years of age and we had very
few people above 63 years of age we see that we have less than 10 people who are basically above
63 years of age now we see that since we have so few old people it's one of the reasons why
basically the survival rate of senior citizens over here is so high it's basically when we try
to calculate the survival rate of the passengers by age we saw that in the age group of 80 to 90
the survival rate is one that simply could be because there is exactly one fellow over here
one particular passenger who happened to survive and that's what's pushing that survival rate to
a very high value and that clearly you know the age decreases as the number of people who are
older decreases and there are a bunch of people who are young there are a lot of people who are
well young adults there are a few people who are middle age so when we say that we are looking at
the distribution of a particular column essentially what we're doing is talking about what its
histogram looked like and we don't see anything surprising over here so this is not what we would
call an abnormal distribution let's take a look at the next question which is essentially what is
the distribution of passengers across passenger class now if you think about this a simple way
to do this would be simply to take the counts of all the passengers in all different classes
and sum them up but we have actually already done this so essentially we have the three classes
over here and we have the grand total of the passengers over here so we can just select these
three rows and create a new chart out of this instead of actually creating a chart through the
usual way which is recommended charts doesn't show anything all of these charts will not work so for
example if i try to click a 2d line it's basically going to give me this but this doesn't tell me
anything one easy way to essentially click or basically view a particular chart which is coming
from the result of a pivot table is to straight away look at pivot chart which we see over here
so let's look at the pivot chart and there it is essentially this is the distribution of passengers
across the three classes we see that this also reflects what we know about the gender ratio
it's high in the first two classes and it's very low in the last class and there are far too many
men in the third class so not entirely surprising that this particular class received many fatalities
so yes this overall may not be a abnormal distribution but what is abnormal over here
is essentially the gender ratio it should not have been so low but then there might be certain
socio-economic factors which have led to this obviously the people who were traveling in the
third class were poor people and remember that the titanic sank in the year 1912 and those were the
times when europe was in the grip of the first world war or at least the onset of the first world
war the economy wasn't great and a lot of people were leaving their european homes to travel to
the united states and one of the reasons why united states was a major destination at that time
was because it had largely been untouched by the first world war so that is why it was perhaps a
reasonable choice for a lot of men to go and seek employment in the united states
and obviously they probably did not have the resources to carry their families with them
if they had then maybe this gender ratio would have gone up but that didn't happen and
unfortunately the titanic sank and so did all these well at least most of these people who
were traveling in the third class
now all of that by the way is just a hypothesis which i have put together
in the spur of the moment using some of my own general knowledge obviously
if you would like to actually validate this with data you're most welcome to do so
and maybe treat that as a homework assignment
let's take a look at the next question which is essentially what is the distribution of
passengers across the fair so essentially what we want to do is simply take the histogram of
the fair column let's move this chart out of the way let's select fair and simply go to the insert
part and click on recommended charts we see that we have a bunch of charts and let's particularly
pick the histogram and there it is we see that a lot of passengers played played like really
really low values and basically about 500 passengers paid less than 18 pounds or whatever
the currency is many of them paid between 18 to 36 pounds many of them between 36 to 54 and
it goes on decreasing that makes sense because the cheapest ticket went to the largest class
of passengers but this is definitely somewhat abnormal because you would expect the curve to
fall obviously because a lot more people will be playing paying say cheaper tickets paying for
cheaper tickets and a lot fewer people would be paying for more expensive tickets but you
wouldn't expect the curve to fall so quickly you would probably expect it to fall a little more
smoothly essentially what this means is that there is this one slot of tickets which has 500
people and the second slot has less than half that amount which doesn't make really too much sense
at the same time we don't even know what sort of division there is between
the fares by class what is exactly the threshold here above which we have the first class rates
below which we have the second class rates and so on maybe that can be inferred from the
cabin information over here so if somebody has too many cabins they like for example this
particular person has three cabins allotted to them and we might want to figure out whether
that leads to a higher fare clearly does you see that 263 pounds is a fairly high value over here
so in summary this chart that we see here well it's definitely an abnormal distribution at least
until we can dig deeper and find out what the what is exactly the logic behind a fair curve that falls
so sharply so this is broadly how you can apply patterns of insights and come up with
so this is broadly how you can apply patterns of insights and come up with different questions
and use those questions to drive our analysis we saw that we went through all the patterns of
insights we drafted a bunch of questions we did not solve all of them in fact you're welcome to
solve the remaining questions on your own and share them with us during one of our interactive
sessions that would make for a really good exercise and you see that just by following
this process rigorously we have at least two or three very solid things to say about the dataset
and that is kind of the point of patterns of insight if you rigorously follow those patterns
if you carefully frame your questions and actually chase the patterns down carefully you will have
at least a few very insightful things to say to your client to your audience and that is how they
are intended to be used so i hope you have fun with this all the best and i'll see you next time